ghost of Tsushima is something entirely
new for Sucker Punch productions it
draws from real world Japanese history
and explores it through the lens of
classical samurais cinema if you watch
the state of play gameplay demo you'll
know there's plenty to sink your sword
into so we spoke to create a director
Nate Foxx to learn more about the game
here's a few interesting things about
ghosts of Tsushima that you may not
already know your gym ball Sucker Punch
hasn't been shy about talking about his
inspirations for ghosts of Tsushima as a
game inspired by classical samurai
fiction and cinema it'll come as no
surprise that the work of the claimed
film director Akira Kurosawa was a key
point of reference for the game Seven
Samurai in particular was a major touch
though however the idea for the game
originally came from a comic book series
called a saga Yojimbo the series which
began in 1984 and is still going strong
is set in the Edo period and features a
rabbit Ronin named Miyamoto Usagi a play
on the legendary Miyamoto Musashi the
series features anthropomorphic animals
instead of humans and creative director
named Fox read it to get a feel for how
to write Sly Cooper he said in an
interview with GameSpot so I'm reading
the saga Yojimbo and it's this big
collection of stories about a samurai
who wanders feudal Japan walks into town
and uses his wits and the edge of his
sword to solve problems I thought man
this will be a dynamite thing and now we
have ghosts of Tsushima Nate said he's
also seen the anime version of rurouni
kenshin so I've got my fingers crossed
for a he talking about toes I easter-egg
respect the blade as well as drawing
stylistic inspiration from Kurosawa's
work Sucker Punch also looked to other
conventions in samurai cinema and try to
work them into ghosts of Tsushima this
includes the swordplay which is all
about quick lethal strikes instead of
whittling away at enemy health bars the
team has also put a lot of effort into
the way nature is portrayed which is why
we got a healthy helping of beautiful
scenery and animals in the state of play
video the other thing you may have
noticed in the gameplay demo is that
after killing the Mongols main character
Jin briefly bowels this is because
sucker punch is also making sure to
represent the respect that is traded
between samurai other swordsmen and
peasants Nate said a lot of samurai
identity
he comes very much from samurai film
however we wanted to do right by
providing a feeling of authenticity and
that meant admitting that a bunch of
American developers did not know what
they were talking about and drawing in
experts from many different fields to
teach us what it was like at that time
we have experts on religion on costume
on motion we brought them in early and
often to review the game is those
partnerships that give you the feeling
of wandering through feudal Japan of
course gin shows respect when he's
operating as a samurai and abiding by
the samurai code in the underhanded
ghost way of life however respect may
not come so readily wind beneath my
wings
one of the core features that
sucker-punch showed off was how wisps of
wind would serve to guide players
towards markers and objectives
I asked Nate how they approach making
players feel like they're finding things
naturally without feeling the invisible
hand of someone pushing them his
response was that the wind is just an
indicator and in fact the game is
designed to distract you with other
things you can choose to pursue in the
state of play demo for example there was
a bear mauling someone and you can
choose to get involved in that you might
also come across a group of Mongols
raiding a farm and you can decide
whether you want to step in in that
scenario they actually said that he
hopes that place don't always follow the
guiding winds as there's a lot to
experience off the beaten path when you
choose to set the wind to go somewhere
that doesn't mean you have to do it in
fact I would hope that you don't I would
hope that you find yourself looking at
hill and seeing some fire and thinking
well somebody lit that fire I don't know
if they're a friend or a foe but
somebody's up there and when you go up
there you're rewarded with content or a
secret that makes your curiosity
justified basically he's saying you're a
wandering Samurai so make sure you
wander live by the sword one question I
had for Nate was whether Jin's
experiences inevitably end in some sort
of combat scenario and while he was
careful about not spoiling anything he
indicated that not every problem will be
solved by the blade sure there's a fair
amount of combat in the game it's a core
gameplay pillar after all but there's
variety beyond that he said there's more
to life than just sword fighting in
ghosts of Tsushima there's also a lot of
people in need and a lot of ways in
which you can serve them this game while
it tracks Jin's trajectory from the
samurai to giving up his identity to
become the go
there are also characters you'll meet
along the way that if you decide to you
can get invested in their stories and in
helping them out it's part of discovery
the overall mission gin is on is to
drive the Mongols out of Tsushima and
save the people but that isn't always
done through burning down shipyards like
in this day of play demo sometimes it
can be rescuing a kidnapped loved one
finding cherished items lost as people
flee danger or helping people survive by
getting them food they describe ghosts
of Tsushima as a wartime epic where you
get to know a lot of people who are
struggling to survive inside a very
harsh landscape here's hoping the
smaller struggles are as impactful as
the bigger ones samurai Champloo the
quick sword slices in the demo made me
think that the combat had a Batman style
counter mechanic so I asked Nate about
that he confirmed that the game
definitely features counters that
require you to have the patience and the
skill to read what the enemy is going to
do and unleash a really devastating
counter-attack however that's not the
only way you can play you can also force
the attack and go after an enemy it's
not just a waiting game but it is a very
skill based experience it wouldn't be a
video game in 2020 without some sort of
reference to a from software game so
Harry is the sole play is kind of like
Sakura in their enemies unleash lethal
attacks they said that this needed to be
the case to make it in line with samurai
cinema but also for realism he said to
feel like those natural samurai movie
Belle's enemies have to die with a few
strokes of a katana otherwise it's not a
katana it's a nerf tube that means that
when they hit you with swords you are
also going to die in a few strikes it's
very challenging Nate mentioned that of
course you're gonna have a bunch of
abilities to give you the edge and
you'll be able to spec out in both
samurai and ghost play styles and switch
between them also you've got a bow and
arrow
it might not be as deadly as some of the
explosives that the Mongols have but it
does a trick
true grit a couple of other things on
combi you may have seen gin raise his
sword at one point
yes gin has a variety of styles you'll
be able to use the combat the Mongols he
was raised and taught in a traditional
samurai style but when the Mongols
arrived and used weapons that are
completely unfamiliar to him he has to
adapt these stances are the new ways
that Jin has come up with to put himself
on equal footing with the Mongols their
stances you choose are part of the
tactical decision-making process
you may also have seen the UI elements
at the bottom of the gameplay video and
wonder what that stuff represents or the
red bar is held for naturally but the
golden spheres represent Jin's resolves
he can use them to regain a bit of
health and they're also a representation
of the grit he has and needs to pull off
the more devastating attacks there's a
risk versus reward element to these
attacks so you have to be thoughtful in
using them and then finally you may have
picked up on the fact that the original
paris games week reveal of Tsushima had
one-on-one duels but the state of play
didn't show any of that don't worry
they're still in the game and based on
what Nate said about them they sound
like intense focused yields between two
warriors that can be decided in the
blink of an eye
a big part of samurai films are duels he
said it's a classic it's two highly
trained warriors meeting and it's going
to be an apex challenge in the game
there are a number of them in goes of
Tsushima where you have to study the
person you're dueling how they attack
how they move read attacks counter and
then look for a window these are the
most challenging encounters you have in
the game and it's just one on one
so basically sharpen those reaction
times there you have it a few cool
ghosts of Tsushima effects that we
learned from a chat with the game's
creative director and Nate Fox if you
haven't already seen the gameplay demo
from state of play check it out on the
channel or on GameSpot calm otherwise
let me know what your favorite samurai
fiction is in the comments below or find
me on twitter at 2 more h
you